[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 F
sport numéro 29 c'est parti pour un
nouveau tour de l'actualité Sport du
département il s'appelle Nice dissein il
est 240e joueur mondial et a remporté ce
dimanche le tournoi de tennis futur de
plaisir après s'être fait un peu peur en
fin de match retour sur une finale 100 %
belle ils seront 25000 ass s lancés ce
dimanche sous la tour eel pour la 36e
édition du paris-vailles nous nous
arrêterons sur cette course toujours
aussi populaire et dans ce 78 sport nous
allons vous faire découvrir la PTK lors
de l'opération santzvous sport les
ctinois ont plus sessayer ce weekend à
ce mélange de badminton et de volleyball
très au Brésil et puis évidemment fin
d'émission tous les résultats du weekend
mais avant de développer ces titres en
image place tout d'abord à notre débat
basket après le titre historique de
l'équipe de France hier soir
mon
SP je le disais hier soir l'équipe de
France de Tony Parker a réalisé
l'exploit enfin le premier titre du
basket français victoire contre la
Lituanie 88 à 60 et pour se mettre dans
le tempo dans le rythme avant de de
présenter de dire bonjour à mes invités
je vous propose tout d'abord d'écouter
l'avis des 5antinois sur la victoire de
l'équipe de France hier soir c'est
génial ça représente la France étranger
donc quelque part c'est le prestige du
pays aussi j'étais très très vraiment
très contente pour eux parce qu'ils
attendaient ça depuis très longtemps et
finalement ils ont gagné persévérance
voilà comme quoi dans la vie il faut
toujours persévérer je pense c'est une
magnifique victoire les basketteurs
français étai très très très dynamique
très ils en voulaient beaucoup et puis
ça nous a c'est un spectacle intéressant
moi j'ai pensé que c'était comment dire
bon c'est un sport que j'aime bien qui
va où ça va vite
où les juges en général sont honnêtes et
puis j'ai trouvé l'équipe de France
remarqué face à eux il n'avait pas des
comment dirais-je des joueurs faciles
d'où on comment dirais-je il y a un vers
célèbre de de Corneille à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire donc là
vraiment il y avait il y avait péril ils
ont vaincu c'est très bien d'où la
gloire ça m'a fait plaisir maintenant ce
que ça m'inspire Ren particulier ça a
fait plaisir surtout pour les joueurs
quoi ça fait un petit moment qu'il
courit après très très belle analyse
hein de des centinois sur ce match cette
finale d'hier soir et pour la débriefé
beaucoup de monde autour de cette table
Isabelle miarabel présidente du Basket
Club de guillancour est à mes côtés
Olivier Mazet agent agent de joueurs
bien connu sur 5 an en yeline et puis
après on parlera évidemment du
Paris-Versailles avec Jean-Marc Frenel
vous pourrez évidemment intervenir dans
ce débat sur le basket je crois que la
première la première question Isabelle
Olivier tout simplement c'est ils l'ont
fait enfin cette génération place au dam
peut-être avec Isabelle ah oui c'est
c'est une victoire géniale là on
l'attendait le plus dur c'était de
passer l'Espagne après ils ont été
libérés enfin ça s'est vu hier soir ils
étaient complètement ils étaient
euphoriqu quoi c'était facile quelque
part cette cette finale le plus dur
c'était le match contre l'Espagne ils
ont perdu trop de fois
précédemment d'affilé c'était c'était
beaucoup trop c'était devenu le chat
noir l'équipe qu'on ne veut plus
rencontrer sur un tournoi en fait
Olivier je crois qu'on commence à
manquer un peu de superlatif par rapport
à la qualification de ce qui est passé
depuis maintenant 3 jours avec la
victoire contre la Slovénie l'Espagne et
puis et puis cette victoire finale là
maintenant pour le titre suprême je
crois que le mot qui revient maintenant
avec insistant c'est délivrance
délivrance parce que ça fait 8 ans comme
vous le dites enfin plus de 8 ans ça
fait 8 matchs qu'on perd contre
l'Espagne de façon consécutive donc déjà
le la victoire contre l'Espagne c'est
une vraie délivrance et puis c'est entre
guillemets la consécration pour deux
générations la génération de Tony Parker
qui court après depuis maintenant 10 ans
qui s'est sacrifié tous les étés pour
venir en équipe de France avec des des
succès mais aussi des des des défaites
et puis des des remises en question et
puis l'avènement de la nouvelle
génération de de Nicolas Batou Antoine
di et cetera et et vraiment je crois que
le maître mot c'est délivrance tout le
basket français je pense que tout le le
le le public sportif français en général
est très content de cette victoire et je
pense que ça laisse présager de belles
choses pour l'avenir comment vous l'avez
vécu cette finale hier soir comme des
millions de Français il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de Français devant leur télé et
des ivinois aussi devant votre télé dans
un bar peut-être avec les amis à la
famille en famille en famille bien sûr
les enfants mon mari tous devant la télé
on était à fond à fond pour l'équipe de
France de votre côté olivierilleur pas
pu vous déplacé en Slovénie ce qui était
pourtant prévu je l'ai vécu en famille
pareil avec de très fortes émotions et
c'était bien de pouvoir je dirais
retrouver les ambiances football qu'on
peut connaître d'habitude et d'ordinaire
sur le sur le le comment dirais-je le le
la télévision française de pouvoir les
vivre en famille et c'était vraiment
très sympa et très convivial s'il y
avait un moment clé de cette finale que
vous retiendriez peut-être pour l'avenir
euh moi je pense au panier d'Antoine l
par exemple qui tire de plus de 10 m
c'est c'est c'est incroyable non oui oui
techniquement je pense que le P
d'Antoine dio c'est vraiment l'action
entre guillemets spectaculaire et et qui
enchante beaucoup d'euphorie dans ce
match là moi si je devais à titre
personnel retenir une séquence de ce
match c'est vraiment la remise des
récompenses et la marseillaise qui est
chantée par tous les joueurs parce que
je pense que c'était vraiment entre
guillemets ce qui a plu au public
général en de de voir vraiment cette
communion ce plaisir cette envie qui
était manifesté et qui était finalement
célébré à la fin du du match de voir un
staff de voir des joueurs qui chantent
qui sont contents d'être là je pense que
moi c'est ce que je retiendrai c'est
vrai aussi parce que on voit un Tony
Parker qui qui à la fin dit je suis fier
de jouer dans cette équipe de France
voilà c'est c'est absolument génial de
de l'entendre il a créé un groupe avec
son avec l'entraîneur ils ont créé un
groupe il y a il y a une ambiance il y a
voilà ils ont fait ce qu'il fallait pour
les amener en finale de cette Coupe
d'Europe Olivier vous vous êtes agent de
joueur je le disais vous vous occupez de
beaucoup de joueurs de proie vous aviez
des joueurs à vous dans dans ce groupe
écoutez on a une histoire qui est un peu
qui est un peu sensible c'est celle de
Ludovic vatti euh qui est donc qui est
donc joueur de proie qui était meilleur
joueur de la semaine des As C cette
année qui était dans les 12 théoriques
pour les championnat d'Europe pour
lequel on a dû annoncer une fin de
carrière pour des raisons médicales
lourdes au mois de mai donc il y avait
il y avait vraiment double émotion
vis-à-vis de ce match bien évidemment la
satisfaction de la victoire et puis un
petit pincement au cœur surtout pour lui
parce que quelque part c'était son
aventure aussi il fait partie de cette
génération de Nicolas Batou Antoine dio
Alexis agensa ils ont tout gagné
ensemble en équipe de jeunes c'était
vraiment l'événement pour lui été
champion d'OPE Junor il ont été
champions d'Europe junior c'était
vraiment entre guillemets la la la
convergence de deux générations celle de
parkerur et celle de de Batou et
compagnie donc c'est vrai que un petit
pincement au cœur et puis bon mes
collègues étrangers qui géraient pas mal
de de joueurs étrangers sur la
compétition Linas klea Goran Dragic pour
la Slovénie donc ouais très très
émouvant quel est le rôle d'un d'un
agent de joueur sur une compétition
internationale comme ça on reste
vraiment au quotidien en contact avec
son joueur ou pas beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins qu'en championnat euh
vous avez un espace de temps qui est
beaucoup plus long entre les différentes
rencontres sur un championnat comme ça
les les joueurs essaient de vivre le
plus possible en immersion c'est-à-dire
de vraiment s'imprégner de la vie de
groupe se détacher de tous les tous les
aléas on va dire extra sportifs et et le
l'agent a vraiment un rôle de backup à
ce moment-là pour vraiment faire
barrière et contre le joueur le protéger
des sollicitations trop nombreuses et
puis gérer un petit peu les affaires
extasportives vous le disiez he c'est
une récompense he pour cette génération
qui qui s'est batue pour avoir avoir ce
titre après les les places d'honneur
médaille de bronze médaille d'argent aux
derniers aux derniers euros quand on est
on tient un club comme comme le vôre a
Guill encour Isabelle on espère des
retombées par rapport à un exploit
historique en fin de compte pour pour ce
sport ou bien sûr on espère toujours on
a espéré avec les
filles qui était au JO donc ben
finaliste voilà on a on a forcément
espéré c'est c'est des mouvements des
mouvements qu'on connaît pas forcément
dans le basket parce que c'est c'est
récent surtout dans le basket féminin
donc et je pense qu'il y a des retombé
clairement je pense qu'il il y a
vraiment des retombées là on a participé
au forum des associations sur sur
guillancour on avait la on a eu la queue
pendant 2 heur c'est-à-dire qu'on a pas
levé le nez pendant 2 heures parce qu'on
avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes les jeunes ils viennent vous voir
il ils vous disent je veux faire comme
Tony Parker c'est un peu ça qu'ils
disent ou pas encore ils l'ont dans la
tête Tony Parker ils l'ont tous dans les
yeux dans la tête Batou c'est pareil je
veux dire ce sont des joueurs connus
reconnu partout dans le monde forcément
ils l'ont dans la tête et puis ils sont
de plus en plus médiatisés donc on en
parle forcément c'est c'est un petit peu
comme évidemment c'est pas le niveau de
du foot mais par contre on avance par là
un petit peu donc la médiatisation joue
énormément je sais que vous allez créer
vous créz là ces derniers temps une
équipe junior masculine ça va être
moteur pour eux là une nouvelle équipe
qui se crée dans un club comme ça avec
un titre de l'équipe nationale juste
avant c'est c'est c'est magique presque
oui surtout pour ces jeunes de cette
catégorie d'âge de cette tranche d'â ge
c'est ils s'identifient beaucoup parce
qu'ils ont l'âge où on a besoin de un
petit peu de de se représenter voilà ce
qu'on voudrait être et donc on crée une
équipe junior parce qu'il y en avait pas
enfin c'est récent dans les Yvelines
donc on ouvre ce créneau sur trois
tranches d'âge on espère qu'on va voir
beaucoup de jeunes on d'ailleurs on
recrute encore c'est un appel pour
toutes les catégories vous allez troué
avec une performance pareille ouais
voilà cadet cadette et enfin
c'est-à-dire à partir de U16 on on
recrute encore au club tout le c'est
complet malheureusement donc on a on a
plus de place chez les jeunes c'est
génial pour nous mais là on le dit il
faudra revenir l'année prochaine pour
les les enfants en tout cas parce que
tout dernière question quel message on
peut donner justement aux jeunes
basketteurs qui vont avoir envie de bah
de venir sur les parquets avec avec
cette victoire Olivier moi je pense
véritablement que que cette performance
c'est c'est
vraiment la marque de de cette
expression on peut vraiment y croire et
tout est possible cette génération a
subi comme je vous l'ai dit de lourds
revers ils y ont cru ils ont ils ont
perd persévérer et et puis je pense que
le message clé c'est c'est vraiment de
voir que on peut être à l'heure où le
sport est vraiment décrié par rapport à
ce débat autour des gens qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent et cetera de la
disponibilité de l'envie de la
simplicité je pense que c'est vraiment
les valeurs qu'on pu véhiculer ce groupe
qui sont importantes la générosité la la
communion avec le public la
disponibilité et l'envie vraiment
l'envie et je pense que lorsqu'on a une
envie qui est débordante comme ils ont
pu l'avoir rien n'est impossible moi je
pense que c'est le message que
j'enverrai on va rester sur belle note
alors rien n impossible et espérons du
coup que bah les jeunes joueurs viennent
du côté de V encs pour pour la saison à
venir et les saison prochaines merci
beaucoup à tous les deux en tout cas
d'être venu débriefer ce bel exploit il
s'appelle Nice dessin il est 240e joueur
mondial et a remporté ce dimanche le
tournoi de tennis futur de plaisir après
s'être fait un peu peur en fin de match
retour sur une finale 100 % belge
pendant près d'une heure et demi il a
sembler être perdu sur le court
Plaisirois pourtant maximeuton connaît
bien les lieux pour sa 4e particip ation
au tournoi futur de plaisir le belge
était tête de série numéro 1 mais voilà
de l'autre côté du filet son compatriote
Nils doin 240e joueur mondial réalise la
meilleure saison de sa carrière dès les
premiers jeux ce colosse prend à la
gorge son adversaire s'appuyant sur une
excellente première balle jusqu'à 64 51
de réalise le match parfait mais au
moment de conclure cela failli se finir
en mauvaise histoire belge le grandil se
met à jouer petit bras maximotum revient
à 54 met la tête de série numéro 2 du
tournoi sa finalement grâce à son
service score final 64 64 de succède
ainsi au français Mar jckel il gagne là
son 3e tournoi futur de la saison et va
se rapprocher de la 200e place mondiale
je suis très content que c'était un
objectif de d'arriver en finale parce
que j'étais tête se numéro 2 mais bon
toute façon tout le monde joue bien donc
c'est pas facile non plus et bah je suis
très content de gagner parce que c'est
le premier FO ici que je joue je joue
bien avant j'ai j'ai pas bien joué le je
pense que j'ai fait le tournoi deux ou
trois de deux trois fois et c'était
jamais jamais bien dans le tableau
féminin l'expérimenté Aurée vedy a dû
s'arracher en 3 set pour venir à bout de
la prometteuse Gael d'esperérier 63
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
4664 après le basket place au
semi-marathon à la 36e édition de de
paris-vailles à 10h sous la Tour Eiffel
ce dimanche va être de est le départ de
cette nouvelle édition pour 16 km
direction le château de Versailles et
pour en parler évidemment Jean-Marc
Frenel le président de Paris-Versailles
bonsoir à vous bonsoir première question
cette année le modor j'ai l'impression
que c'est NON au gigantisme
oui c'est dire que depuis quelques
années on souhaite faire en sorte que
tous les concurrents parcourent cette
magnifique épreuve avec ce magnifique
parcours dans de très bonnes condition
et moi mon expérience de coureur et
l'expérience d'autres autour de moi
montre que il y a certain nombre de
courses qui qui vont jusqu'à 25 30 40
voire 40000 inscrits et on s'aperçoit
quand même que c'est devient très
compliqué à gérer et que je suis pas sûr
que l'ensemble des participants soit
satisfait de de cet environnement donc
moi je fais en sorte que sur ce parcours
qui est un peu compliqué parce que à
mi-parcours quand on traverse la forêt
Meon est remarquable mais on a un espace
réduit donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je je fais so en fait que il
y ait pas plus de 25000 participants et
25000 qui soient contents 25000
participants vous le disiez ça fait fait
quand même déjà une belle marée humaine
hein les départs comment sont-ils donnés
alors on fait des départs ce qu'on
appelle par VAG c'estàd que les grandes
courses le font toutes maintenant nous
on le fait depuis quasiment l'origine
depuis 75
1975 pour les raisons que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure de parcours à un moment qui
qui est très réduit et en fait on fait
partir 350 coureurs 300 320 350 selon le
nombre coureurs par minute donc il y a
60 vagues qui font effectivement à peu
près les 25000 coureurs sur 1 heure mais
vous pourriez
accueillir plus de participants enfin
vous vous avez la la ressource on va
dire il il y a beaucoup d'inscriptions
refusées chaque année par exemple oui
oui puis qu'on a clos les inscriptions
cette année au 20 juillet donc on peut
estimer a peut-être 3 ou 4000 personnes
qui auraient bien voulu s'inscrire ou
qui trouvve toujours un tout un de
moyens essayer de le faire mais qui n'y
arrive pas oui on pourrait le faire mais
je disais tout à l'heure enfin on disait
C cette course ENF moi je veux pas faire
une course en disant je j'ai ma course
est la plus importante par le nombre je
crois pas je pense que c'est toutes les
raisons que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup
d'amateurs qui viennent sur cette course
parce que le le semi-marathon est
toujours un peu plus abordable que le
marathon alors nous on est encore un peu
plus petit qu'un semiarathon puisqu'on
fait 16 km malgré les difficultés de de
l'épreuve de par pour la côte mais en
fait oui parce que on s'était rendu
compte quand même à l'arrivée que la
plupart d'abord on d tout à l'heure sur
un exploit personnel enfin la course à
pied c'est aussi sa propre son propre
performance quel que soit le niveau on
fait sa propre performance mais les gens
cours souvent Paris Versailles la
première épreuve qu'il vient de faire
dans une compétition c'est celle-ci
après ils iront000 marathon voir au
marathon mais 16 km maintenant bon jamb
broute cour une ou deux fois par semaine
voir le dimanche une bonne heure bon
parisvailles ça peut se faire disons un
corant moyen va faire en 1h3 donc c'est
ça fait pas aussi peur bien sûr queun
semi-araton on va mettre quasiment 2h
sur le parcours en lui-même vous en
parliez il y a ce ce cette traversée de
de la forêt de Medon la tactique de
course peut-être le le point le plus
important du parcours quel est-il cette
année c'est la l'entrée dans versaill
peut-être avec la petite côte cette
partie là je dira un petit peu plus en
avant c'estd que on a l'impression
queune fois qu'on est en haut de la côte
on a on a vaincu le Graal et ça y est on
a plus qu'à se laisser dérouler jusqu'à
l'arrivée non parce que d'abord il reste
c'est la mi-cours seulement et puis une
succession de petites bosses autour de
voflet dans la forêt de enfin bavéis
Chaville et ces petites bosses dont
notamment un viroflet qui fait 3 400 m
de long mais qui fait très mal parce que
là on est au 13e km donc il y a de la
fatigue et cetera et puis l'arrivée
surtout lorsque la météo est avec un
vent d'ouest qui est à cette période de
l'année assz assez fréquent on a 2 km de
de vant de pleine face sur l'avenue de
Paris à Versailles une avenue très large
donc en fait sur lequel le vent peut
s'engouffrer et là il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de de gens qui
souffrent énormément parce qu'on voit la
ligne d'arrivée qui est à 1 km et on est
on avance on la voit de loin ouis il y
aura des des grands coureurs sur cette
édition 2013 comme d'habitude ça fait un
petit peu une tradition beaucoup enfin
beaucoup une dizaine de Kan éthiopiens
enfin courur d'Afrique à qui eu prétend
à la victoire dans l'ordre de 46 47
minutes et puis malheureusement on a
plus beaucoup de Français hein donc même
si on a quand même quelques Français
j'espère quelquesuns font dans les dans
les 20 premiers bon cette course alors
pour le haut niveau l'intérêt c'est que
les gens viennent aussi dans le haut
niveau parce que elle est pas très
longue donc ils peuvent courir cette
enfin ce type de cours toutes les
semaines donc ce fa dire que des
coureurs qui ont envie d'un petit peu de
de de de se frictionner un petit peu
avec les Éthiopiens ou les kéans
viennent aussi chez nous pour cela par
rapport à ce record qui a été établi par
le Marocain et la chimie vous croyez que
dans dans ce peloton que vous avez cette
année en 2013 il peut être battu ce ce
46 minutes un petit peu plus peut-être
pas encore cette année alors j'ai pas
j'ai plus tout à fait le nom en tête
mais il y a un jeune coureur qui avait
fait 5 ou 6e l'année dernière qui est
qui est éthiopien qui je crois cette
année a fait vraiment une très belle
performance à lî et encore un peu de
maturité à venir et je pense que ce
coureur là sera un grand d'ici un an
vous parliez de la météo tout à l'heure
pour quand on préparait l'émion vous
vous m'en disiez de mots justement il va
faire très chaud cette semaine par
rapport à la semaine dernière ça va être
compliqué de gérer cette chaleur qui va
peut-être y avoir dimanche prochain oui
alors paradoxe c'est qu'en septembre
fait souvent aussi chaud enfin peut-être
pas que cette année au mois d'août il a
fait très chaud mais c'est vra il y a
souvent un espèce de d'été indien qui
revient sur cette période et euh il y a
plus de 20 ans enfin je crois que la
dernière fois où on a vu de l'eau sur
Paris versaill c'était en 1989 donc ça
fait déjà très loin euh c'est vrai que
la météo aujourd'hui montre bon
particulièrement brillante aujourd'hui
demain après-demain on va attendre un
petit peu d'avoir les tendan mais c'est
vrai que sur ce weekend on a quand même
plutôt une tendance avec de la chaleur
donc on est en train de prendre
réfléchir aux mesures qu'on doit prendre
nous pour faire en sorte que ça se passe
bien on va arroser les coureurs on va
leur donner peut-être plus d'eau on
tient être vigilant on travaille
beaucoup avec les services de santé sur
sou cette limite et fait le paradoxe
c'est quand on rentre en forêt il fait
beaucoup d'humidité et c'est justement
des points dangereux donc rendez-vous
pour voir les les les meilleurs
peut-être à l'arrivée à versaill vers
10h45 11h 10 vraiment grand maximum
grand maximum parce qu'ils partent à 10h
donc ils mettent 47 minutes donc
effectivement un petit peu avant avant -
10 et puis euh le gros de la masse enfin
du gros de la course populaire va être
en dem et M demi voilà voà merci
beaucoup Jean-Marc d'être venu sur le
plateau de TVfil et à dimanche pour pour
la course ce 36e parisvail à dimanche
prenez un filet de badminton un volant
un petit peu particulier vous échauffz
bien la paume de votre main avant de
jouer vous pourrez pratiquer la PTK ce
sport brésilien était en démonstration
ce weekend à la base de loisirs de 50
ans en yeline lors de la 2e édition de
santvous sport images d'éodim
moine
rassurez-vous votre téléviseur est bien
réglé ces quatre joueurs n'ont pas de
raquette et pourtant il semble bien sur
un terrain de badminton mais il s'essaye
à la PTK ça se joue avec un filet de
badminton et le principe c'est d'arriver
à marquer le point en faisant passer le
volant de l'autre côté donc du filet
avec un maximum de tro passes de chaque
côté du
terrain pour marquer un point il faut
que la PTK gros volant à plume touche le
sol et ici c'est la paume de la main qui
sert de raquette même si la précision
n'est pas toujours au rendez-vous et la
main un peu fatigué après quelques
matchs le concept est adopté j'ai
vraiment découvert aujourd'hui je savais
même pas que ça existait donc vraiment
découverte totale aujourd'hui et je
pense à refaire ou sans sans hésiter
c'est pas plus dur que le badminton et
le volet mais il y a des automatismes
àquirire déjà oublier qu'on a on a pas
de raquette dans la main utiliser
uniquement sa main donc donc voilà ça
vient pas forcément naturellement mais
voilà au bout de d'un peu de temps et
d'un peu de pratique je pense qu'on on
s'amuse assez rapidement la PTK est
originaire du Brésil mélange de
volleyball et de badminton ce sport
traditionnel est le plus populaire après
le football et s'il n'y a pas encore de
fédération en France Nicolas et Muriel
entendent bien devenir de vrais
smatcheur de
[Musique]
PTK
place tout d'abord au football et ce
weekend les terrains cinquentinois n'ont
pas été très prolifiques en terme de but
4e journée de Division d'Honneur tout
d'abord à Versailles les Versaillais
recevaient les lilas et les joueurs de
David jigay ont partagé les points à
montboron source score nul et vierge Z0
partout c'est leur 3oisème match nul de
la saison en qure rencontres ils n'ont
toujours pas débloqué le compteur
victoire il reste 11e au classement en
promotion d'honneur dans la poule B
traape recevait saint-onlomon euh pour
le compte de la 2e journée également
match nul les traapises conservent tout
de même leur 4e place de son côté
aiguille en cours se déplacer à saint-mt
vous le voyez à l'écran et s'est incliné
2-1 le SG a aussi du mal hein comme
Versailles a lancé sa saison coincé à la
9e place du classement en rugby 2e
journée de fédéral 3 on suit toujours
plaisir qui se rendait à Vincen et le
persc s'est incliné d'un tout petit
point 16- 155 malgré deux essais
inscrits les joueurs de Philippe Béard
ont tout de même obtenu le point du du
bonus offensif défensif pardon place au
basket les dirigeants de l'étoile de
Chemino de trappe nous les avions reçus
il y a quelques semaines espère toujours
un miracle après auprès de la Fédération
Française de Basket après leur recours
déposé contre leur relégation en
National 3 à l'inter saison l'équipe
traapiste a tout de même évolué dans
l'optique d'un éventuel maintien
National 2 le staff sa-quantinois a
réussi tout de même à conserver ses
recrues avec ce début de championnat en
N3 on
l'écoute nous avons formé notre équipe
au mois de mai au mois de juin pour
jouer en National 2 et pour jouer le
haut du tableau en National 2 et les
contrats ont été signés de cette manière
et ils ont appris on leur a rien cachché
mais ils ont vu qu'il risquaient de
jouer en National 3 et c'est un risque
de plus en plus probable aujourd'hui
donc il est évident que c'est une
déstabilisation psychologique mais je
dois dire que je tiens à les féliciter
tous ont été d'accord pour jouer le jeu
aucun
n'a résilié son contrat et malgré le
côté ext sportif il fallait tout de même
se concentrer sur la reprise du
championnat avec la réception de
Gravenchon au gymnase pa maillet ce
samedi qui sonnait bien creux he il faut
le dire d'ailleurs les deux équipes ont
livré une prestation très défensive ce
qui explique le petit score final 59 552
mais l'essentiel pour les traapistes
était de gagner ce premier match pour se
lancer tout de suite à l'assaut de la
montée en National 2 on reste dans le
basket d'autres résultats toujours en
National 3 dans l'autre match de cette
poug les hommes de tente le chaîn et
Versailles se sont imposé sur le parquet
de wasel 80 à 74 leurs homologues
féminines en National une connaissent un
apprentissage difficile du au niveau
amateur pour leur premier match depuis
14 ans à ce niveau les joueus de
Stéphane Roulet se sont inclinés 72 à 52
face à Saint-Paul rosé mené de 7 points
10 minutes de la fin du match les
ilinoises ont craqué dans le dernier
quartan place au handball maintenant le
championnat de franceç féminin de
National 2 ouvrait ses portes ce weekend
il reprenait Montini se déplacçait à
plouvorne après le leur facile victoire
en Coupe de France la semaine dernière
les joueuses de Stéphane paysan se sont
passé sont passé complètement à côté de
leur match et se sont incliné 29 à 25
une dernière info résultat le r quet
c'était leur premier match en National
de cette saison et les chocs des
lancours n'ont pas fait le poids face à
anger défit 11 à 4 vous voyez le score
qui s'affiche une dernière compétition
qui s'est passée ce weekend le mod des
ça vous dit peut-être rien du tout et
pourtant la première édition se passait
du côté du camp militaire de frilus à
Ben m de comprenait une journée dans la
boue est une épreuve intense saliant
défi physique et mental le genre de
challenge en fait he pour tous ceux qui
pensent que courir n'est pas suffisant
il était plus de 13000 sur la ligne de
départ pour les 13 km à parcourir au
programme 22 obstacles à passer dans des
conditions drastiques glace Bou eau et
barbelet électrifié et pour finir ce 78
sport vous en avez l'habitude quelques
dates pour l'agenda du weekend n'oubliez
pas le Paris Versailles he ce dimanche
départ à Paris à 10h au pied de la tour
effffel avec une arrivée prévue vers
10h45 11h au moins 10 pour les tout
meilleurs et puis vous pourrez assister
ce samedi soir au premier match à
domicile des féminines de lais Montini
handbal face à Ici Paris coup d'envoie à
20h30 ce 78 sport touche à sa fin
nouvelle version merci de l'avoir suivi
et continuez à nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs via les réseaux
sociaux et Twitter bonne soirée et à
lundi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prochain